The mainline Conjuring movies may be coming to an
end — but could James Wan's horror universe live
on without them? The director has finally
addressed if the series has an afterlife.
Crafting a successful horror franchise
is no easy task, but James Wan has struck
gold with the Conjuring saga. These movies are
inspired by the cases of real-life paranormal
investigators Ed and Lorraine Warren, who are
played by Patrick Wilson and Vera Farmiga,
respectively. Of course, these chillers
might be somewhat questionable when it
comes to their "true story" elements. However,
there is no denying their effectiveness as
entertaining horror flicks. So, will
The Conjuring 4 continue that trend?
"Sometimes it's better to
keep the genie in the bottle."
The first Conjuring movie tells the story of
a family whose rural farmhouse is haunted by
a supernatural entity. The Warrens are called
in to solve the case, only to discover that the
evil that dwells there isn't willing to go down
without a fight. The Conjuring 2 sees the Warrens
traveling to London to help a single mother save
her children from an unwanted houseguest. Finally,
The Conjuring 3: The Devil Made Me Do It
pits the paranormal investigators against the
American legal system as they set out to prove
that demons inspired a man to commit murder.
Every film in The Conjuring series has made
serious bank at the box office, and they've
been generally well-received by moviegoers too —
so Warner Bros. Pictures is undoubtedly interested
in making more. According to Wan, however, The
Conjuring 4 might be the saga's final entry.
As it turns out, James Wan isn't interested in
producing more Conjuring sequels for the sake
of it. The filmmaker has too much respect for
the Warrens and the universe he's built around
their cases to churn out mindless sequels.
During a recent interview with Collider,
the horror maestro confirmed that The Conjuring
4 is still a work in progress and explained why
he and his team aren't rushing to bring the
fourth installment to fruition. He said:
It sounds like Wan and company are focused on
making a movie that lives up to the quality of
its predecessors. However, while The Conjuring
4 might be the final movie in the main series,
it doesn't necessarily spell the
end of this cinematic universe.
The Conjuring franchise has mastered the art of
the backdoor pilot, with the main movies featuring
cameos from memorable spooks that then went on
to star in their own spin-off series. As such,
the universe will likely live on in the
form of spin-offs after The Conjuring 4.
For example, the Annabelle series has produced
three movies. Elsewhere, The Nun will unleash its
second installment later this year. It remains
to be seen if there will be a follow-up to The
Curse of La Llorona, but that film grossed over
$100 million at the box office, so you can never
rule out the possibility. Unfortunately,
Wan's Crooked Man feature is apparently
no longer happening in its original form, but the
project may be revisited somewhere down the line.
Of course, The Conjuring 4 will undoubtedly
introduce another spooky entity that haunts
the nightmares of fans all around the world.
If that happens, who's to say that the demon
in question won't be given the spin-off
treatment as well? The Conjuring movies
might well be one foot in the grave, but it
looks like there's life in the franchise yet.